it's time to babble the [ __ ] on live
from the world-famous improv it's
Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
it is Friday night in Hollywood so let's
babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Ralph Garman
[Applause]
thank you wonderful people for selling
us out yet again here at the world
famous improv so far were three for
three I think is that right yeah
now we're [ __ ] I can only go down from
here man
that's right well is there anything
after a three-peat before Pete I guess
that's too much expectation
I'd much rather keep the expectation low
man I like to float rumors like we're
about to break up I think it benefits
the show can I share a quick Babylon
story Babylon related story I would love
that
I was I was mentioning traveling I was
traveling today at one point I left I
was leaving it Atlanta and I was in that
was I in Atlanta was it here Oh how
stoned are you [ __ ] honestly very
because I was away for two days
well three total but two days of like
foreign very weak we compared to like I
came home and like California Bureau and
so yeah I'm smoking you old man he'll
show a PBS California amazing anywhere
California pure
yeah this dude I was in a went to the
bathroom in the airport I go to take a
leak man I swear as I'm heading into a
stall I think I hear somebody go hey hey
and I was like holy [ __ ] man like I've
always heard about this but I might get
some [ __ ] toe tap in action yeah like
somebody's trying to blow me here man
like this is gonna be interesting I
closed the door and what I wanted to do
was change my shirt because I was like
all sweaty and whatnots nothing you're
Superman yeah totally I was just like I
can't know so I'm changing my shirt and
I hear again excuse me
and then I'm like don't be so bold as to
assume it's for you it can't it wouldn't
be for you in the stall at this point
yes and I'm waiting for a knock but it
never [ __ ] comes and so I changed my
shirt and [ __ ] and then I leave the
stall and when I leave the stall there's
a dude wearing plastic gloves and he
goes don't be scared I know who you are
time to check your prostate look like
[ __ ] Dexter man it was just like
ready to go with the [ __ ] plastic and
so I was like oh right on how are you
and I assumed he meant like the movies
or something but [ __ ] it right away he
goes I love Hollywood babble-on I was
like I'm on my way home and I'm on my
way from flying home and tonight at 10 I
actually do Babylon he goes oh my god
could you just [ __ ] say my name on
Babylon and I was like yeah totally and
he told me his name but I forgot but I
did write down his twitter address so
I'll give it a Twitter address just in
case you're curious because the the
thing is he wants to take a picture and
he had a phone right but him as his was
full and so I was like I'll take it and
then like I'll send it to you you got an
email address or something like that and
he gave me his Twitter page and so I was
just like well if you want to be on the
show up I'll put the [ __ ] picture on
the show and then you could get the
picture off the Babylon page man so his
name is he's at at a and a W and an emu
s anonymous no one's ever gonna never in
a million years but this is the [ __ ]
picture that we I did the selfie of us
do you got it yeah yeah everything
was there any explanation as the way he
was wearing plastic gloves in the bath I
honestly didn't want to ask but I didn't
know if he was a food server if he was
actually working in the bathroom but
either way I was like probably not a
good idea for I felt like Howie Mandel
was fist bumping and she arrived but he
never offered to take him off so I guess
the only have one pair something like
that nice guy anyway anonymous on
Twitter all right there we go but it was
weird the bathroom hookup aspect of it
not what you expected not a little
disappointed yeah glory hole action in
there instead I just wound up taking a
picture but I was I was at the airport
because I was coming back from Atlanta I
went I can't say a lot about it but at
the last minute AMC was like hey do you
want to go out to Atlanta to the walking
dead set oh I know and and shoot some
interstitials they're coming up on this
an event I don't even know how much I'm
allowed to say it's so crazy how [ __ ]
tight-lipped everyone is there they keep
a literal shroud of secrecy they make
you sign a lot of things in one night
except the zombies they have no lips
I've noticed most of them they just are
just teeth just falling off [ __ ] file
it that's how it's gonna be all right
so so I go to do the the brake the
bumpers if you will you know between
like hey man you're watching the
marathon stick around and stuff like
that I interview a lot of people behind
the scenes I met like almost the entire
cast
I talked to people work on and whatnot
it was fantastic but Gale Anne Hurd is
the producer right and Gale Anne Hurd if
you don't know her she's one of the most
successful producers in the history of
the movie business near um not to
mention one of the most successful
female producers in the history of the
movie business I think she's only
surpassed maybe by Kathy Kennedy in
terms of like a box office and stuff so
she goes as far back as terminator like
she just got she drippin with with geek
movie history and whatnot now she's the
producer of the show of The Walking Dead
so while we're there boom I walk into
her as she's coming out of the office
and she's like oh Kevin you're here
today and I was okay I'd met her once
before to comic-con or something like
that so I was like yeah we're shooting
all over she's like going down to the GL
and I was like yeah yeah she's like
you're gonna be down by the jail she's
like you got to get bug spray on
and I was like wow I'm pretty much
covered from head to toe like a Muslim
woman so III don't know where else she
would find she's like your legs your
calves are wide open she goes here and
she's carrying this bottle and she
kneels down and she starts spraying my
[ __ ] legs and I'm just looking down
and I was like if I could go back in
time until the 13-year old keV Smith
that let the [ __ ] lady who made the
Terminator
off on you yeah like a mom and [ __ ] it
was so amazing and I was like I could do
that and she's like now I know how to do
it and stuff I was like thanks so much
and then later on I interviewed her for
the for the interstitials but it was
cool man you try to get a [ __ ] one
piece of information in regards to
season four nothing no and they're all
terrified like the moment you think they
get close to revealing something like a
[ __ ] red dot shows up on their head
you just see sniper lawyers like no but
it looks cool and I did see there's some
[ __ ] that we weren't allowed to point
cameras at and we couldn't shoot in
front of but I did see some cool stuff
I'm gonna ruin it all oh no [ __ ] no
because I don't want to get the call
like we just cancelled comic book man
loose lips sink ships you fat [ __ ] clip
yeah but there is there's a there's some
cool [ __ ] that happens like coming right
up there I think they said they're on
Episode four or five or something like
that in terms of shooting but it looks
like there's something cool coming like
I'm actually excited and they wouldn't
tell me anything else but I saw some
[ __ ] where I was like oh always going
someplace new with it but it was it was
rather exciting then I decked out a
little bit can I guess can I guess what
it is yeah Brad Pitt shows up and
there's a lot more [ __ ] zombies
coming over the wall did that open opens
tonight today I think right tonight was
World War Z World War Z world wars
orders the word thus far I haven't heard
good things really why would anyone I
just don't understand why anyone would
bother making a zombie movie right now
it's zombies right yeah yeah because in
the trailer they just show bodies they
don't show like we're undead or they're
just fast-moving zombies they're just
[ __ ] Rockstar zombies yeah
like Olympians ambe's I just saw in a
world where we get to watch the wall you
know where I get in a world and they've
got hours to tell a [ __ ] story you
know and they still have the kills and
whatnot I just took a [ __ ] head off
with a cleaver and [ __ ] and there's
still the excitement but it's all about
the human drama why would you bother
making a [ __ ] movie where you got to
pack everything into two hours the only
thing you can offer more than the
character development and the effects
they do on the show and all the effects
are pretty much real people walking
around in makeup right the only thing
you could offer is like we got millions
of zombies and they're all [ __ ]
digital and [ __ ] like that it just
seemed like a really a waste of time and
effort man look he's got 14 kids that
need to eat man what are you gonna do
brothers got to make a buck I can't hold
it against Brad he's got to make a
living I think that was like the big
that's the job right it's a zombie movie
with Brad Pitt that makes it important
yeah um but he had it for a while
correct yeah from what I understand he
developed the book he read the book and
loved it and he started developing it
and that book came out a while ago Molly
before the Walking Dead TV show started
I think maybe here so that's a matter of
timing like if he had gone first people
be like holy [ __ ] but since it follows
the Walking Dead it feels kind of like
redundant to me I don't know anybody see
it today I seen it yet that's one guy
there's your home and he's doing this
he's doing giving us this he silently
put his hand up and then he [ __ ]
silently was just like winded um be
genuine believable
how I felt about man steel well you
really didn't like that zombie movie
Jesus we won't get into that tonight it
was so [ __ ] creepy and quiet man he
was worthless
it looked he looked like a little girl
from Schindler's List who's just like
alright let's get into the meat of figs
shall we each and every week we like to
give shout outs the people competently
long distances or a celebrating special
occasion see right there it's for it's
all over the place
chairs a little movie tonight it's a
segue we call the shout outs
[Music]
to cap shikaka you don't need to stop
him anymore man I don't know preset of
gaps did you set it to not keep playing
where she's Gabby around Gabby quit it's
cool I'll stop let's just see what
happened just a test okay it's a good
[ __ ] thing man now we got a little
preview yeah it's not set for the okay
don't worry
Oh God we just showed everyone behind
the curtain yeah that's okay they don't
they still love us I'm Elena
and Ian there you guys Wow right up
front
my name is milena and my best friend Ian
and I are here seeing Hollywood
babble-on live for the first time I want
to shout out to my beautiful girlfriend
Taylor yes Ralph and Kev just in case
you couldn't put that together I'm a
vegetarian oh she's a hot Majan yeah
they're all hot vegetarian the moment
anyone's like I like [ __ ] I'm like me
were you always a vegetarian ever dabble
and did you eat meat before you went
total you did yeah and it wasn't for you
a lot enough to last a lifetime
Taylor I going on two years now and she
is the Maggie Sawyer to my Kate Kane
well those that's a little comic book
reference yeah it's just one problem
there was someone else Taylor's been
having a long ongoing affair with a
certain transvestite transform
transsexual Transylvania I was hoping
that perhaps if she heard dr.
frank-n-furter's sing to her it would
keep her bed warm till I get back
thanks a bunch for all the laughs and
babble the [ __ ] on milena how do you do
I see you've met my faithful handyman
he's just put out because when you
knocked he thought you were the Candyman
I'm just a sweet transvestite from
transsexual Transylvania
[Music]
there you go and to think my father was
worried about me when I got into drama
in high school the voice of an angel man
I want you singing at my funeral I want
you to sing like you hide from the
coffin for me to be singing I'm going
before you I'm sure no no no yeah I eat
like a [ __ ] pig
yeah but I'm so angry I'm just gonna
burst into flames I know just one day
I'm just gonna literally burst into
flames just all the anger and angst will
just consume my body yeah
little big scanners a big smile just
explode one day now you're so mellow and
stoned all the time and every day you're
not gonna die so much it just slowly
sort of melt at something looking for
I'm looking for the Oh to death man
where I'm just like I'm tired and then
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and then you just lay the hound if I
could drop some last-minute bombs and
get the [ __ ] out man yeah I'm definitely
going the Vader way are you yeah more
like the Emperor I'm gonna toss me over
into it Jake he actually went pretty
cool Vader yeah yeah well I won't go
that way Ruth and Beth are you guys here
tonight you are so [ __ ] here my name
is Ruth and I'm coming to the show
tonight with me is my friend Beth who
has never heard not once
Babylon or seen the show well she should
be enjoying herself by now we both both
work at that theme-park down in Anaheim
Miller's a guy is very farm no so some
utter filth would be amazing to help us
forget that we have to be super clean
acting every day at work I'm a huge fan
of the show but I decided to keep her in
the dark about anything Babylon until
she came with me tonight well it's like
the worst surprise ever Kevin could you
please welcome Beth to the show and let
her know exactly what she's in for in
your creepy sexy voice thanks for all
the laughs for the past three years Ruth
hey where you at girl don't work that
glitters
[Music]
till that [ __ ] as bitterest let me give
you a little taste of your dear home
away from home your Disney home let me
take you to a little ride called it's a
small world it's a small world after
[Music]
it's a small world after
[Music]
it's a small world after I like the
little whimper it's a small welcome to
Babylon there you go we are never
getting the front of line of anything
ever there Jason and Julia from Toronto
Canada you guys here eh oh yes they look
surprised it here's why because this
message came to me from your friend
Shana she wrote this on your behalf I
want to send a shout-out to my very good
friends Jason and Julia have flown all
the way to see your show from Toronto
Canada hopefully they won't be too shy
to identify themselves they were like
this when you call their names and
hopefully Julia won't kill me for
sending this in Julia and I are both
longtime listeners and fans of the show
her fiance Jason has never heard a
complete episode wait a minute a
complete episode so you started hearing
some of it and said [ __ ] this and turned
it off that's what I'm assuming Jason
he's like I'm a huge [ __ ] fan of it's
a small world eh it's not funny
that gave me hours of enjoyment that
right
but he loves Batman and dick jokes well
there you go you're in the right place I
was hoping that Bane and Arnold
Schwartzenegger could welcome them to
Los Angeles and give them some advice
for planning their wedding well who
better to talk to about happy happy
wedded bliss than Bane and Arnold
Schwarzenegger I did not know I was a
wedding planner yeah here's the thing
about weddings if you get married then
you can [ __ ] a maid it's amazing how it
works out you know I was a Batman
villain too you know
just like you we have something in
common that way you and I were both like
you know brothers from other mothers but
no one cared who I was till I put on the
Basques it's a cold time in the old town
tonight I used to see you welcome
welcome yes for all the way from Toronto
we got to get up there we're gonna do a
Toronto which I agree completely this is
Michael and Todd are you guys in
Chewbacca's here today for khloe
kardashian yeah
your sister just gave birth shouldn't
you be back at the hospital she'll eat
it they had to keep Chloe away from the
newborns
she was like a hamster
Todd writes one of my oldest friends
Michael will be celebrating his 31st
birthday at the show this Friday we've
known each other since second grade I
haven't I haven't liked anyone for that
long our friendship was forward for the
power of comic books and Star Wars we
could not ask this is gonna make me cry
really bad Hulk music we don't [ __ ] I'll
look for you keep reading that day we
could not ask for a better event than
HBO to celebrate this joyous occasion a
bunch of our friends have come out
tonight to bask and all of your babbling
glory some of us have known each other
from our high school days and we have
gotten older and some of us have moved
away and started other chapters in our
lives if you could please give my friend
Michael a bowi birthday song we'd really
appreciate it thanks Todd the least we
could do for you guys considering you
came all this way for Michael's 31st
birthday how many of that whole table
already of you putting it in each other
this guy's grabbing a girl maybe later
well I wish you all the best
all right so happy birthday Michael from
Todd and the gang David Bowie here we go
happy birthday to you mine and your
friends and like extenders they all love
me they love
[Music]
your evening with happy birthday to you
birthday - beautiful
you and I have known each other since
the second grade back way back
happy birthday to you
[Music]
stop it
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday it's my least favorite
part of everything I'm getting good with
it though I could spin it like there's a
light for you in the circus I'm trying
to do a cat's cradle with it next time
this last email came from Galvin Davis
in Sydney Australia the final email and
he asked for a specific bit that we've
actually even got a theme song for now
he wanted to hear a ranting Christian
Bale do something so I think it's bail
time what who did that that's so
sometimes very entertaining but I get to
rediscover it every week I'm like wow
this is funny
Galvin Davis from Sydney Australia are
you here where are you Galvin right
there in the back all the way from
Sydney Australia so I felt obligated to
fulfill his request came all the way
from Sydney Australia to babble the [ __ ]
on I've listened to every single
Hollywood babble-on
and knew that my trip to Los Angeles had
to include witnessing the dynamic duo in
the flesh I'd like to request a movie
franchise crossover [ __ ] fight can we
hear ranting Christian Bale and Harrison
Ford argue whether Hans shot first or
not this is gonna be a little difficult
out it's gonna pass but you came all the
way from Australia so I'll give it a try
okay here we go
I shot first oh good for you
oh you shot him first naughty naughty
naughty naughty dah I was in Star Wars
no no no I saw it it was Jar Jar Binks I
was in the good Star Wars [ __ ] you
you were not done professionally mate
there you go there's your crossover we
also get emails from all around the
world each and every week featuring
Kevin's reactions alright
speaking of Han Solo Tony Vargas writes
I read somewhere that Al Pacino was once
up for the role of Han Solo is this true
actually I did a research and he was in
London last week and he did an evening
with Al Pacino and he talked about all
the roles that he didn't accept that he
was offered and apparently one of them
George Lucas asked him to be Han Solo in
the Star Wars films
I think I'd heard that once before he
was also offered the Brando and Martin
Sheen roles in Apocalypse Now that he
passed on and Richard Gere's role in
pretty woman in a very different film
say hello to my little friend I paid for
you so blow me credits a very short film
but yes Tony Perla Pina was offered Han
Solo he was wondering what that might
sound like wow yeah the Millennium
Falcon made the Kessel run and 12
parsecs whoo come on kid
let's blow this thing and go home yeah I
don't think it would've been as good
with the Val Pacino Kristin and
Australia rights
g'day from Down Under I was browsing the
internet and I stumbled across something
I thought Kevin would like a delicious
chocolate treat that he would especially
be interested in giving what he likes to
do well for those who don't know her new
to the show
Kevin Nam is a guy who likes to eat no
no oh you evil bastards like if anyone
was gonna say everything why did it have
to be people in the front
he likes analingus he likes to perform
it before me he likes to enjoy your
wife's Bob I'm an ass eater
yeah so Kirsten in Australia found this
on the Internet she thought she would
like this it's a chocolate treat mate
for men like you I think can we show the
picture up from the internet this is a
real thing
this is from the UK it's called edible
anus and it is chocolate [ __ ]
but it's pure Belgian chocolate so while
you're eating the chocolate sphincter
you can enjoy the fact that you're
eating a pure Belgian chocolate
sphincter and it comes in three shades
too it comes in I just wiped wipe too
hard and hasn't wiped at all yet we need
to get them as a sponsor edible anus
calm yeah absolutely yeah go buy some
chocolate [ __ ] so that's the best
kind of [ __ ] they have around you one
made a chocolate she didn't know if
you'd seen it or not but you thought you
might enjoy I have seen it many times
I've never gotten a box hint
well Christmas isn't coming becoming a
lot harder if I'm eating chocolate
[ __ ]
Doug hawkster jr. Doug did a very cool
thing he said I'm going to post uncut
episodes of Hollywood babble-on on
YouTube but I'm gonna stick whatever
pictures of videos are included in the
show throughout the course of it so a
lot of people say to us how can we see
the pictures and videos that you guys
showed a live audience when they listen
to the podcast and we always post it if
you go to SModcast comm and you go to
the Hollywood babble-on page and you
click on the episode if you click on the
number it has all the photos and all the
videos that we show during the show but
what he's done is he's run the the audio
underneath and then he's laid all the
stuff on top of it so you can watch it
on YouTube in one sitting
it'd be better if you did it on our
channel rather than stealing our content
and putting it on his channel and just
because he puts [ __ ] our pictures
under it as well and I mean that seems
like theft to me no especially because
he's putting on his YouTube channel he'd
get enough hits on that they give you
some [ __ ] money and [ __ ] I mean I'm
not one of those cats it's like don't
bootleg because I used to get bootlegs
back in the day but like I'm still alive
it's like
this is all I got is this [ __ ]
Babylon show man don't take that away
from [ __ ] me and Ralph look Doug
you'll be hearing from our lawyers
that's what I what it is yes it's no
good for our channel if you do it for
our Channel throw them a couple bucks
every week to do it I love that [ __ ] man
just do it for us all right I'll give
them [ __ ] in advance like we'll give
them the podcast in advance so that by
the time the podcast drops the YouTube
episode could drop as well yeah yeah
you're a smart guy that's nice fun I am
I'm just like there's no point in
fighting it like you can't fight the
creative urge this dude loves our art so
much he likes to watch it on his xbox
which has a youtube app so he gets it
there and then he loves our [ __ ] it
makes him want to make his own [ __ ] you
don't want to like stifle that and be
like Foca don't do it or will sue you
what you want to do is [ __ ] recruit
them and be like help us do it and
[ __ ] we'll work together and [ __ ]
alright seems more democratic Doug
you'll be hearing from Kevin he'll be
stopping by your house and big boxes of
chocolate [ __ ] as a president
hopefully that'll be the start of a
relationship me and Jay will be at his
front door dressed in costume and show
Susie opens door below ours this email
comes from Mike caper he said in honor
of Man of Steel doing such boffo big box
office business last weekend
yeah that'll help he sends us a clip or
link rather to the most hilarious
bootleg Superman toys ever okay this is
a great great sign I want to send a
couple pictures from this it is Superman
toys some are legitimate most of them
are bootlegged it's at flavor wire calm
you can check out yourself but I've
brought in some of the highlights for me
since man is still such a big deal this
is an actual Superman toy this was a
legitimate one this so had the licensing
and everything this is the Superman fly
um hi parachute the only problem with
this toy is Superman doesn't need a
[ __ ] parachute he flies well what a
bad toy what if he was flying and
suddenly it was a very overcast day
there was no sunlight and he's like
powerless need the parachute then it
makes sense I can make it work man that
could work I personally enjoyed the
knock-offs I like the bootleg toys I
like the ones that are done in Mexico or
China where they're trying to make a
buck it's very entertaining like this
next one this is super heroic man and
you know metropolis is safe because he's
on his horse with his lariat so in case
you know Brainiac comes along you can
just throw out a noose around it
that was from a Dark Knight figure at
Elseworlds Dark Knight figure and they
just put a Superman cape and head on it
and a mullet apparently yeah and then my
personal favorite Superman of course
longtime member of the Justice League
but if you wanna make a Justice League
toy I'm guessing that probably cost you
a couple bucks you gonna put Justice
League of America on the toy heaven so
these people found a way around it
this is not the Justice League this is
the sense of right alliance
[Laughter]
and I want to be a member of the sense
of right alliance because its members
are one of the cars from cars Superman
Batman of course spider-man has joined
in the blue Power Ranger and Shrek of
course because you wanna round out you
want to round out your crime-fighting
team with someone who knows the swamp
you man I would take that [ __ ] team
over the Avengers they got a Hawkeye
these [ __ ] have Shrek donkeys
like a team trip who's this man donkey
how would al pacino sound is donkey Wow
Oh
Shrek that princess she's also a troll
the ladies up front of like look at his
face that's more things are happening
Michael M writes a new Captain America
is gonna come out someday soon I think
it's next year Mike I was worried about
you and Kevin having an opinion whether
cap is still a virgin or not I say yes I
believe he has the forties virtues I
won't have sex until marriage
my friend says no he isn't a virgin he
says after saving the world and
adventures he gets it every day what are
your thoughts he doesn't get capped man
I agree I think cap is a virgin no way
he's not he's not a virgin what do you
mean I'm saying he's not a virgin Oh in
my opinion I don't any factual evidence
out of photos of him banging someone
there's no selfies those selfies with
Cap'n you know Scarlett Johansson going
at it I'm just saying he knew he was
going into battle right he knew he's
going into fight even back into the 40s
in World War two he knew he might go
into a mission he might not come back
from just taking your Christmas gift
back in my head I'm just saying there's
he's gonna say look he's gonna be run
into one of these nurses or field their
female shield agents or something I'd
say listen I might not come back from
fighting Red Skull and you know so
speaking of skull how'd you like to do a
little battling of your own with Hydra
so I think he probably got some before
he got frozen in the ice that's no way I
think he's virgin [ __ ] not you Cap'n
yes yeah Jose Vasquez right it's been a
fan of the show but a fan of Kevin's for
a long time
new fan of Ralph's my son introduced me
to Hollywood babble-on a couple months
ago and I've been through all the
podcasts now I found the Germans bit
especially funny every time I hear them
every time I hear em I think of a
different picture I'm not quite sure
what they look like but I've made a
poster of a movie perhaps they could
star in I hope you'd get a kick out of
it Jose Vasquez here's the photo that he
put together for a film version of what
he thinks the Germans look like it's
it's called the naughty Nazis and it's
kid and me and Molly the monkey justin
bieber's monkey altogether in spank the
monkey is the name of the film yeah
yeah it's a good movie I think we should
go see that yeah yeah like being clink
actually your sergeant Schultz I'm clink
oh my god that's right yeah
and you kind of have that I see nothing
look at your fancy I [ __ ] live my
life by that mantra man I see nothing
but kind of hugs my favorite show
speaking of the Germans Gary price in
Arizona has a suggestion for the Green
Lantern oath as the German so I think
it's Green Lantern oath time non geeks
in the audience of course the Green
Lantern when he wants to recharge his
powering the superhero he has to say a
certain oath in order to get it to
recharge and that is something we've
been reciting now for many episodes this
request from Gary price says Germans
plus green enter an oath equals [ __ ]
awesome let's see so it's a duet it's
you and me doing the Green Lantern oath
which we just take turns back and forth
then we'll chime in at the end together
as the Germans shall we okay all right
you owe me a good start okay in
brightest day yeah it's very bright
in blackest night symfon and via candles
the night shots is so black night
blackest night no evil shall escape a
sight that because we are the ultimate
evil yeah yeah we are yes
so we know it when we see it you know
that's why it doesn't escape besides we
know uh yeah we do let us her worship it
was might know a key the Jews one long
dude Jesus thank God somebody here has
some case let those who worship evils
might beware my power Green Lantern's
light
I was less than I expected
yeah yeah doctor who's Jesus Christ
every week we like to say goodbye to
some folks in show business who have
left us too soon
yeah this everybody knows this week's
particularly tough we're gonna save him
for last so we got a couple other people
to give salutes to before we move on
it's called Tinseltown steps and now
another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed few people left us
this week including Bernie Sol ins you
may not know the name but you know what
he did he co-founded a comedy troupe in
Chicago known as second city he was the
guy who put second city together
Bernie Salle's died this week at the age
of 90 he co-founded second city in 1959
and throughout the years I'll give you a
list of some of the talents who passed
through those doors Alan Arkin Alan Alda
Peter Boyle David Steinberg Robert Klein
John Belushi dan Aykroyd Bill Murray
Gilda Radner Eugene Levy our Andrea
Martin John Candy Martin Short the list
goes on and on and on he went on he
founded it in Chicago then he moved to
Toronto they built a second second city
in the early 70s and that was most of us
for Dan Aykroyd and Gilda Radner came
from that's where those guys were put
together and they also had Eugene Levy
and Andrea Martin and Kathryn and
Thomas's Dave Thomas Catherine O'Hara
Martin Short John Candy and then they'd
he also developed along with the
producer named Alex Alexander a show
called sctv and I know SNL gets all the
attention that's been on forever
everything but when I was in college for
me and my friends sctv was the [ __ ] I
mean that was the other thing we loved
watching and they were they were a
sketch comedy that wasn't based stage
based so much there's no audience so
they would shoot their pieces they had
far more Liberty it was all TV spoofs
basically pretty much set in melon melon
bill Nolan Phil yeah and I remember
watching Martin Short do ed Grimley
which was the character that he created
and before II took to SNL yeah he did it
on SCTV and all those different
characters so this guy is known as the
patron saint Doug McKenzie came from
that's right great why North came from
wow this dude so without this dude you
and I don't see all these people and go
oh my god maybe we can do let's do that
yeah like this guy gave him a home
someplace to go be [ __ ] weird and be
experimental and do comedy that was
outside of like wearing a suit on a
stage talking about [ __ ] weather and
cities and [ __ ] these cats were so
experimental they busted the mold
completely and without Burnie solitary
silence his name yet
well I was he wasn't he was the man
behind the curtain
that's why I wanted to give a huge
bucket OEM man these are great fellow I
must say if I say so myself okay how do
my ed Grimley I love doing yeah
Slim Whitman passed away this week I
can't believe it anyone even knows who
the [ __ ] Slim Whitman is he was mighty
brave is that slim Slim Whitman was the
yodeling cowboy he were I who sold
albums at midnight before like he was
the first like big star of selling
records in commercials and infomercials
on television but here's the thing
that's how most people know him but he's
been he was a star in the 40s and 50s it
was like a huge massive country-western
star Elvis Presley used to open for him
in the 50s that's how big he was The
Beatles were huge fans of his he had
been a recording artist since 1949 sold
like 65 million records before he ever
got to television but his star waned and
so to revive his career he went on
television which made him successful but
the same time kind of a joke because
this guy had horribly dyed jet-black
hair and a pencil mustache and like
suits that Liberace would think were gay
and he was had this yodeling voice and
and he went on late-night television but
end up selling hundreds of millions of
records via the power of television
laughing now well not him he's dead I
remember at Mars Attacks movie the Tim
Burton heart attacks that's what his
Indian love go when I'm calling their
heads would explode remember anyway
here's a little piece of the Slim
Whitman commercial that many of us grew
up watching late late at night here's
the man himself who passed away this
week at 90
again with you now the magic of Slim
Whitman is badass the industry we are
all new to record collection and best
loved favorites
[Music]
yeah he's all gone now you guys don't
you don't get it it was such a simpler
time where literally you could be like
standing against those trees and pretend
to sing that's right and we'd all be
captivated by that commercial agree with
Josh down the number yes you had to call
it wasn't like simply click on this and
fall down the rabbit hole you had to do
and you couldn't pause that commercial
there was no DVR you had to wait and
carefully [ __ ] eight eight hundred [ __ ]
[ __ ] I missed it now I gotta wait again
until it comes back on again now I gotta
how do I order my Slim Whitman album
trust me kids it was a nightmare back
when we grew up it was horrible you
always got somebody on the other side of
the phone it was just like why do you
want this yeah and of course lastly this
week everyone was stunned and shocked at
the news that James Gandolfini passed
away this week at the age of 51 yeah we
understand the clapping is hoping it's
for James not not for the fat lady
passing died of apparent heart attack in
Rome hardest part of the story for me
was that his his teenage son who he's
traveling with at the time was the one
who discovered him and I wish that on no
child he was at a film festival in
Sicily apparently vacationing with his
pair Amina I went to that film festival
threats it's beautiful it's on Sicily
it's like on a mountaintop and Sicily
with his giant open air what do they
call those things amphitheater oh it's
gorgeous and and the amphitheater was
built like at in 800 BC it's nuts going
crazy old but a beautiful town man and
he was up there for a retrospective of
his work they were gonna show a bunch of
good episode of The Sopranos and what
not so he was there to watch some some
of the older stuff he's down with the
stuff that put him on the map made him
massively famous he watched the night
before I think it was he died before the
before he ever had such a bummer he was
Tony Soprano of course from 1999 to 2007
when a won the Emmy for Best Actor in a
Drama three consecutive years in a row
he was nominated six times in total and
it did a lot of great work in film to
let people look over the fact that he
was great and bad true romance of course
place our songs me
that soul even though he was like a
hidden bass and he has that moment with
Alabama he's like you got heart kid go
ahead and he opens his shirt take a shot
yeah that stabs his foot yeah but he was
that was where I first saw him and then
also he was in the submarine movie
Crimson Tide Crimson to get shorty I
remember him in that is one night when I
cast him is Tony Soprano man like from
just that opening sequence of the drive
the Jersey Drive he commanded Authority
and I played this weirdly complex
character I mean you think of it now as
like throw a rock you hit a show where
it's like the hero is a dirtbag but this
was like the first one the first time
they presented you with somebody was
like oh my God he's [ __ ] vile but
you're rooting for him it would be like
watching Star Wars and being like this
is all about Vader [ __ ] I'm back in
Vader's play so and it was his soul that
did it that brah he was also enormous ly
charming as an actor he loved his family
regardless of what he did at work he
loved his wife he loved his kids you
know Tony Soprano I'm talking about was
the level of the character I brought in
a clip just as a tribute this is one of
my favorite moments from The Sopranos
this is him being enormous ly
light-hearted with his psychotherapist
dr. Melfi who played by Morocco very
Braco yeah and I thought it was the
humor into the humanity that he brought
to the character that was what made it
so successful here's a little scene of
James Gandolfini in The Sopranos we
talked about that when you started some
people get insomnia others stomachache
or headaches but it usually passes out
of any other side-effects that you know
of some people experience a diminished
libido they have a hard time getting or
maintaining then go I say hmm you know
not all impotence is a result of the
medication you say into something wrong
with me when's the last time you had a
prostate exam hey I don't even let
anybody wave their finger in my face
great moment 51 years old it was from
New Jersey's well not only when he was
here Jersey icon but he was actually
from the Garden State as well and by all
reports like an insanely sweet [ __ ]
guy I think did we do the Hollywood
helper where he was helping somebody out
of the snow yeah yeah we did fairly
recently and also people I know work
doesn't been work to them at one point
Ben was just like oh my god what an
amazing Duty was all heart and stuff he
was looking out for Ben at a good time
really nice guys big bucket of win issue
with you its cauldron of web and we also
each week like to look at showbiz
celebrities who are able to get away out
of the way of their own ego and their
own self interest and help other people
to segment we call the Hollywood helpers
[Music]
yeah John Malkovich is one of this
week's Hollywood helpers you hear this
story in Toronto what this guy did know
he's doing an opera on the road and he's
touring around Canada with it it's he
plays [ __ ] he doesn't play she could
play anything man he plays Casanova
thank you so much Casanova is there
anything of the name and he's at the
theater and he's outside having a
cigarette break and this guy's walking
down the street this guy from Detroit
worse to work for General Motors with
his wife he's retired now and he trips
on the sidewalk and he falls into a
scaffolding a construction scaffolding
there on the street and the way he falls
his his throat falls in between two
pieces of scaffolding oh and the jagged
scaffolding tears his throat open oh
[ __ ] oh man killed as a [ __ ]
Wonderland of mouths yes they don't they
don't promote that when the Tourism
Board is trying to get you to go there
but it'll
Toronto for our scaffolding a yeah so
he's there and he's smoking a cigarette
and the guys bleeding out there in front
of him and Shh I've never forgive him
for this he puts the cigarette out
douche bag that costs money by the way
this especially in Canada but that's
right the players they're expensive so
he throws that out and he goes over any
ministers first aid to this guy stops
the bleeding puts pressure on the wound
and another guy comes up with a towel
and he puts it on there and they were
able to keep him stable until paramedics
could arrive and got him to the hospital
the man is okay he will survive but they
said if Malkovich hadn't been right on
the scene intervene and and helped as
quickly as he did the guy and it would
not have made it so Alcatraz well done
man
to which I show you cigarettes
save lives I've always said that as I'm
outside smoking thank you sir thank you
thank you let's all light up what do you
say right now no we can't do that in
America anymore this [ __ ] country's
gone to hell man I'm just thinking of
Alcatraz saving that dudes life and as
they're taking him away he's like pay
that man he's money and our other
Hollywood helper is Robert Downey jr. oh
I love Robert Downey jr. I please man
right before I came here I was watching
rewatching Iron Man to which some people
try to tell you it's not very good I
like Iron Man 2 a lot I did you IIE is
just [ __ ] Goldeneye was one of those
performers who just makes everything
he's in entertainment arm the worst of
his films and it's also it's just you
know what it is too aggregated practice
you're talking about a dude who's been
doing it since he was a kid and so he's
like a finally fine-tooth comb and he's
a sharp [ __ ] razor so by the time
like the Avengers Iron Man comes around
nobody could be Tony Stark but Robert
down yeah he was ready to go oh damn
girl he's filming a new movie right now
in Western Massachusetts called the
judge and there was a woman named
Heather denno who's one and a
half-year-old son is a huge Iron Man fan
and they found out they were in his
neighborhood and so he she took her son
to go meet Iron Man and so she goes and
she get
to the set and she says my son loves
Ironman it was impossible for mr. Downey
jr. to have a conversation with my son
so Robert Downey jr. busy superstar in
the busy superstar in the world probably
right now said yes I'm sure I'll say
I'll say hi to your one and a half year
old son
so mom says you're gonna meet Ironman
and so they take them back and the kid
meets Robert Downey jr. ha ha and a 1
and a half that's not the same [ __ ]
thing we've got a photo of their
interaction of what happened when one
and a half year old Jackson that Robert
delegated
[Laughter]
the look on Robert Downey jr. faces like
[ __ ] from a one-and-a-half-year-old give
me a bad review this looks like a photo
of me and my old lady after [ __ ] are
you the one crying there you go
disgusted look on your face I'm the one
with the hand on the back like sorry
it'll be okay
I'm not Iron Man after this photo was
taking apparently Robert a junior picked
the kid up and had a long conversation
with him and explained to him the whole
situation and by the end the mom says
they were the best of friends by the
time they parted that's horrible so that
made me feel better but Roberts like
really I just and what are you doing let
your Wonder half your old watch Iron Man
anyway that's priorities thank you every
week only way that story gets even
better is if the one and a half year old
was like the [ __ ] you guys do to the
Mandarin I love that character you're
marginalized him it's unacceptable
spoilers every week we like to take a
look at moments in TV and movies that
slip through the cracks hundreds of
pairs of eyes see every project you see
before it gets to you and yet still
their [ __ ] that should not be
[Music]
this week's [ __ ] that should not be is
appropriate because it comes on the
heels of the release of Man of Steel of
course Rob Patton if I sure Scotland
writes in that he was watching Superman
to the original of cinematic appearance
of General Zod and he said I noticed in
the fight scenes where Superman is
fighting with General Zod Ursa and Nan
in the streets something seems a little
off with the spectators and I've noticed
this myself in that film have you caught
this senior sometimes here's a here's a
quick quick video shot of Superman -
while Christopher Reeve Superman is
battling Terence Stamp as General Zod
you may not catch the [ __ ] that should
not be in this scene while we watch it
but we've got a still store for you so
take a look at Superman -
[Music]
[Music]
then dyers who deserve to
[Music]
did you catch it did you catch what what
was all [ __ ] up about that scene let's
throw the scene up so you notice it cuz
I know I did when I watched it can we
show the picture of that one moment of
the spectators looking at Zod battling
Superman yeah all of the words in the
scene are totally [ __ ] backwards they
reverse the shot to get everyone looking
in the direction of Zod and Superman and
it says no entry
I remember watching even though the
theaters like what what did I just see
what is this bizarro world did he
already go did we spend the world
backwards already and now I'm saying
[ __ ] that's a that's upside-down bad bye
Lois may be furious that is still a
great movie man that holds up but if you
remember that the big battle between him
and General Zod and two other henchmen
Ursa and none they they destroy a
coca-cola sign yeah
maybe a gas truck fire member correctly
yeah and that wall and that's it it's
not like the [ __ ] 40 minute building
smell it's not [ __ ] orgy of the curse
I'm really the death toll in Metropolis
that was in Man of Steel that's that
that's absolutely true it's a 2 for this
week because while we're talking about
[ __ ] that should not be we also do a
segment we call exquisite acting where a
list actors turn in less than a list
performances and this week's star of
that is Terence Stamp who played General
Zod of course in
[Music]
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with Ralph's dominance peter Brooker of
the UK sends in i thought you'd like to
see the short clip of Terence Stamp in
the limey he of course played General
Zod in the original Superman films I
thought this scene would also make a
wonderful ringtone he writes and I think
Terence that was a brilliant actor it's
been for a long time he does chew up the
scenery a bit in a film called the limey
which if you've never seen from 1999
Steven Soderbergh directed it it's about
a British gangster who finds out that
there's a guy who killed his daughter
basically he goes after him with a
vengeance as you can imagine a gripping
stuff very gripping but sometimes larger
than life this particular moment with
Terence Stamp again who played General
Zod is particularly entertaining for me
here's a scene from the limey from 1999
you tell him you tell you I'm coming
tell him I'm [ __ ] coming that would
be a great ringtone I'm gonna try that
out tonight when I get home he should
less of the Robert Downey junior with
the little boy and more of Terence Stamp
I think in your bedroom is what you're
not agree man yeah every week we also
like to take a look at moments where
Kevin is inserted into situations he
does not belong it's a segment we call
keV in
maybe some dudes but what's kept in this
week well here's the thing about this
week it was weird it was it's like there
was some sort of unspoken memo that went
around and a lot of the pictures that I
sent in this week were not of Kevin in
places he doesn't belong but of me in
places I didn't belong garm and it's
Garmin this week and if you'll allow me
I just wanted to show these because
we're this week all of a sudden it was a
bunch of photos that came in featuring
me in places that were odd to see me
there are enough [ __ ] pictures of you
in the world the man inserted into
things as far as I'm concerned Matt
writes I know Hollywood babble-on has
the what's Kevin segment this week I'd
like to suggest a moment be set aside
for what's Garmin this is a movie that
he imagines me in with you know Emma
Stone you know I feel bad Emma Stone
yeah so here is his poster for the new
feature film it's a remake actually of
the of the Michael Douglas film
Romancing the Stone
this is gar man sing the stone yeah
[Laughter]
Kathleen Turner that's for sure you're
so full of hope I know I would destroy
her by editing
Nathan Gonzales writes in I'm suggesting
a subject recurring segments for the
show called glugging with Garmin where
Ralph's drinks with famous people
throughout history which is an idea he
suggested this scene from Casablanca
would be appropriate to start things off
this man me and bogie and the Sam
sitting there at the and the cafe
getting loaded I look shit-faced too by
the way
Bogart looks better than me in that and
he's dead
and then the last one is attributed to
my my now sadly departed mustache it's
it's from Pat Evans here II said in
order to memorialize my mustache Garmin
P I is the last voice it wasn't a porn
stache you know I speaking as a man who
killed recently owned a mustache I
resent the the assumption that a man who
wears a mustache is immediately some
sort of pedophile or porn star it was
hurtful
that's the dive don't think of either of
those things when I think of mustache
all I think is [ __ ] catcher
all right well each week we like to look
at what's happening in show business
news with the HBO headlines
[Music]
well Kris Jenner has another [ __ ] on
her stable a baby is a blessing in most
cases yeah its most cases [ __ ] tape star
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West had their
managers right give it up too man I'm
like not giving him credit but it she's
gone from [ __ ] tape from a [ __ ] tape to
like now everyone knew that she had a
baby and we're waiting to hear two
babies [ __ ] name that's a pretty fast
climb yeah there were a [ __ ] I heard
there were three guys at cedars-sinai
with gold frankincense and myrrh who
actually were waiting outside in the
hallway that's how that's how
significant she's become we have a
little taste of the Kim Kardashian theme
before we get started
[Applause]
well the world does because we're all
waiting to hear what she named her baby
the baby came several weeks earlier than
her July 11th due date everybody saying
what are they going to name this baby
girl that Kanye and Kim had an official
word came out today it is North West as
one word or two disappointed is it one
word or first names North middle names
West no middle name first name North
last name West because Kanye West if
don't even see the [ __ ] pond yeah oh
my god man so it's a North no middle
name
west northwest that's cute actually no
stop it
why I mean it could have been part of
the [ __ ] problem you see this is you
and you're all accepting attitude sure
let everyone do whatever the [ __ ] they
want man named her North they named the
child a direction stop the madness
[Applause]
[Music]
this poor child is gonna be named after
a compass point you're like well that's
kind of cute it's not cute I'm and my
kid after a comic book cares
fine hardly is a name that people have
right north is a direction that people
go maybe that's the idea maybe they're
like you know and if you're in a bird
north you can't combine it with your
last name West
you can't put two directions in one name
that's in the Bible
the Lord sayeth thou shall not name your
child after direction if a direction
already presented itself Asst Caribbean
1701 eight years of Catholic school I
don't remember well you should have paid
closer attention listen listen this
child is already [ __ ] okay this is
it's it's a it's a father whose trust me
in it look what is he is he still around
who knows who knows whether dad is still
around or not oh really do you think oh
wait hold on
you think Kanye and Kim are gonna get
married it's gonna last forever Syria to
[ __ ] be serious so she's already got
that strike against her and she's got
the grandmother Kris Jenner who is going
to be selling her into white slavery as
soon as possible
and then you name her North which is
gonna get your ass kicked on the
playground why do you do that to her
this kid's gonna breathe such [ __ ]
rarefied air it doesn't matter what they
call their man it's shocking that they
went with something fairly low-key like
North instead of God West or something
like that could have been bad there's
actually an I swear to you I didn't even
see that [ __ ] pun man I was just like
wow that's weird Northwest why would you
go and now that you explained I'm like
Oh name your child after a pond no
that's what I'm saying that's just
horrible it sounds like something you
talk about like 3:00 in the morning when
you're drunk right and then like the
next day you're like yeah we'd never do
that that's a horrible idea can I share
this is my Kardashian story and where
I've learned to like [ __ ] be careful
or look before I leave I don't even know
they argue that there's some tie-in
lesson here I'm trying to figure it out
my kid was on my podcast last week
episode of SModcast so we're sitting
around and I'm just talking to she's
about to be 14 this week I'm just
talking about what the average teenagers
into and what nine we talked about her
taste in music movies well you know kids
today kinda yeah we eventually get to
television and that's where we totally
split cuz I'm like alright tell him what
you watch what your favorite show is and
she's like I watched the Kardashians and
that was like why kid why and she's like
they make me feel smart that's the only
reason I can let anyone watch the
Kardashians but it doesn't end there
dude shoot dolly which but this is the
problem this is where I was like no at
tu brute eh
she doesn't just watch the Kardashians
if she watched them on TV so [ __ ] be
it we're already paying for cable she
downloads the Kardashians from [ __ ]
iTunes so I'm like that means [ __ ]
when you're paying for it and for that
so I've been supplying or supporting the
Kardashians for the last year and a half
Wow I felt a little like a Judas as well
you should
but I also felt like I bought that
little kid some baby clothes
well I'm sure North will have her own
line of baby clothes within a matter of
weeks you will release it in stores
everywhere that's the first brand and a
fragrance yes you'll have a fragrance
you'll have a fragrance as well ah North
by Northwest will be to be the name of
the fragrance I will I smell like shitty
diapers and I would not be surprised if
this is the first human being that they
try to trademark slash copyright yes
exactly there Brandon this kid Hardman
just this week I thought maybe we're
gonna have a Justin Bieber story but
Justin came through for us in the final
hour god bless him
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right Bieber has pissed off an
entire company this time a jet airplane
company he was in Miami because he had
to be at game at the the NBA Finals game
there to watch the heat play the Spurs
because he has to be anywhere there's a
camera he's got to be so he's in Miami
and he hires a private jet to fly him
from Miami to Burbank the jet was
supposed to take off at 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Time in Miami they are there
they're waiting he calls says I'm gonna
be a little bit late he shows up well he
doesn't show up four hours go by and the
company's there and they're gassed and
the pilots there and the raised hand
fourth or four hours go by he's paying
for the flight he's not paying for the
waiting time what do you mean meaning he
pays for the flight that it takes the
time to go from when he leaves this is a
private jet yes I disagree they charge
you for all the time on the ground if
you make them wait you got to pay for
all that time good bets that makes me
feel better yeah
but they would like to get on the air in
the air rather because they have to go
and the pilot also has a certain amount
of duty time and then he has to check
out right so yeah he's waiting because
he's on the clock and after a certain
amount his shift is over then he's got a
split may have to bring another pilot
out and it gets very confusing so
they're there and four hours past and
3:00 p.m. rolls around and still no
Justin Bieber and they say why aren't
you here yet and he says well I have to
go pick up my monkey from West Palm
Beach tips pond a pinky no not that
monkey another [ __ ] monkey he
abandoned in Germany not the [ __ ]
monkey put into the the Auschwitz of of
a monkey place it quits [ __ ] he's got a
new monkey he wasn't replaced he's got a
new monkey how many monkeys does this
guy need he's a monkey hoarder so he he
had to pick up his monkey from West Palm
Beach so he hires a helicopter to fly
him from the airport in Miami to West
Palm Beach to get his monkey okay and
they're still waiting for him five hours
later still no Bieber no monkey and and
apparently around 9:00 while Adan
[ __ ]
t-shirt no monkey that's my that's my
battle cry nine hours after the initial
scheduled take off 8:00 p.m. he finally
finally leaves he paid for all that time
I mean it's not he didn't he he may have
inconvenience somebody and as much as
the guy was like I would have rather
have flown you dropped you off and done
but he paid for all that time but what
more importantly is the question maybe
he's a tech but he paid for all that
what about his disposable monkey problem
how about [ __ ] weird man
he keeps buying monkeys then leaving
them place this is he's an [ __ ] who's
the [ __ ] who sells him another monkey
after like world headlines has him going
to Germany and getting his monkey not
only taken away but he's like [ __ ] you
I'm leaving and he takes off so who then
sells them another so you play monkeys
are Russia's when she that's what your
problems with with with the underground
monkey dealers it's just he's a dick yes
but who helps him out is it he who helps
as it says in the Bible right sure right
after death another passage he who helps
verily Bieber no Bieber no monkey that's
right
Amanda buys was in the news this week
[Applause]
I would like to respectfully as amanda
bynes because we only have a two-hour
show to slow the [ __ ] down cuz I just I
just I've been just we're writing just
pages and pages of Amanda Bynes so we
could do a whole Amanda Bynes special if
we wanted to she was in Atlantic City
New Jersey this week she was at a hotel
who knows why maybe she was getting that
webbing removed from her eyes or
whatever her problem is but she was in
the hot tub by herself staring intently
at her phone tweeting constantly and
people came up to her and said can I
take your picture you're [ __ ] crazy
and she said yes but if I don't like the
picture I get to delete it from your
phone or camera so everyone who wanted
to take a picture with her had to sit
there while she went through your photos
and decided whether it was acceptable or
not we've got a picture of her looking
at pictures of her in the in the hot tub
there she is she would evaluate the
photo and if she liked it then you would
get your camera back if not she would
delete it and if she didn't like the
photo I'm pretty sure she'd put it in
her ass I'm not sure but I think it
happened so she's in the hotel lobby and
there's a guy there with his kids 56
year-old man named Bobby Cohen who takes
a picture with his iPhone while she's
walking through the lobby and he thinks
that's the end of it
big mistake Bobby she lunges at him
after he takes the photograph she
catches him taking it and says sir I
need you to delete that you can't take
pictures of me she insisted that he turn
over his iPhones that she could approve
the photograph Bobby didn't understand
the rules apparently when it comes to
crazy-ass batshit Amanda Ville and so
she starts chasing him around the hotel
where nananananana nananananana
he complains to hotel security because
she won't stop pursuing him he keeps
walking away then running away and she
keeps chasing after him insisting that
she turn over his he turn over his
iPhone to her hotel security eventually
had to physically remove her from the
lobby so she would stop pursuing this
man in his iPhone that is the stuff of
nightmares right there chicken a fright
wait go and give me your phone she's
been very active on Twitter this week as
well dr. drew tweeted about her this
week saying it was time to perhaps leave
her alone she responded with the fact
this me see if I can see the tweet here
you're ugly she said about dr. drew
that's her catchphrase man if she has
something against you a matically via
twitter you are ugly I want you to leave
me alone she said via Twitter good point
she also said about Drake remember she
wanted Drake to murder her vagina
I remember the UH then she said Drake
was ugly I'm guessing because he didn't
murder her vagina I'm guessing that's
what the problem was now she said she
was sorry about what she said about
Drake and she also then tweeted
afterwards I could never marry a German
because I'm Jewish what's fine yeah
why'd you have to be all racist about
all these things you are tweeting yea
Germans are nice have a very nice we
made the oom-pah-pah music that massage
yeah yeah chocolate Oktoberfest that was
good yeah and hate Holocaust yeah sure
we have a few minor penises working f
cking with the book ended up meanwhile
here's the thing we're all we're all
suckers because a man days faking the
whole time she's making this all up is
she she like [ __ ] uncle junior on The
Sopranos she's just we're not sure if
she's tweeted a publicist friend of hers
this tweet or this text rather this week
that he put up on the internet we have a
shot of the
this is their text this has all been an
act and you know it I am an actress I
know what I'm doing she wrote her
publicist friend seriously he wrote I
mean I don't know what drugs were a part
of it and may you also have something
mentally wrong I've got two million
followers now everyone wants me I am
smart and not stupid everyone mentions
my name the world loves me
she writes so the whole thing's an act
man that's a filter man that sets
definitely if you look through one prism
I guess you could draw that same
conclusion as she is but why who is the
publicist her publicist no just a friend
why I was reaching out and saying are
you okay and she tweeted she tweeted she
texted Rhett and he tweeted that because
he said he wants the world to know that
she's okay
well she he just blew her [ __ ] cover
man right now ferret what a dick
back to our Teen Mom Farrah Abraham's in
the news this week as well I know we
don't have it to tie the paper but I
think we need one no no I think we need
one every week every week we talk about
her we don't have one to play will use
calm the [ __ ] down you people I just
said we don't have one will you [ __ ]
listen for God's sakes I say no theme
song dude everybody does anal why does
she get a theme song for it because
she's a teen mom Kevin she's a she's a
role model for other teen moms she
announced this week that she is getting
well she's nuts that she's getting she
got her second breast job because she
know she wants to be a restaurant tour
and she wants to go back to school so an
important part of getting a further
education is getting triple d' tits
stapled on to your small frame that's
what I've been working on all this time
is trying to be a restaurateur
that's why I have these large boobs but
at least she took in touch weeklies
photographers into the surgery with her
first the biggest problem for Tara
backdoor Teen Mom Farrah Abraham was
deciding how big to go you know what
it's like when you know you're trying to
weigh a bigger decision in your life
we've got a photo of her in the in the
doctor's office trying to figure out
what's going she's the worst [ __ ]
actress in the world how [ __ ] do I
want to be that doesn't want to be like
Triple D [ __ ] double D [ __ ] but she
decided to go just with a large D and
she went into the surgery room and she
had the photographer's come in with her
and I think we have a photo of her going
through the surgery there she is
I'm just guessing this isn't the first
time we've seen Farrah Abraham knocked
out from drugs naked with some guys hose
in her mouth
I'm assuming this is this is a situation
we're all familiar with
it's an intubation tube right well sure
if you want to call it that I would call
it a practice [ __ ] but I think it's so
weird man like a dope atado her whole
body's on display you could see her
boobs you see the like the marks where
they're gonna cut into her she's got the
intubation tube and she's got a hair net
I'm like don't [ __ ] with my hair that's
right speaking of the dumb and booby I
enjoy it a lot of people make fun of me
but I enjoy watching the beauty pageants
I like watching them because know of
this you will watch sometimes the
perfect collision of cosmetic the
attempt of cosmetic perfection and then
the the failure of the brain perfection
you'll see those two just run into each
other like a car crash and sometimes
when it's when it's right when it's one
is perfect when it's magical this this
kind of stuff happens this is Miss Utah
USA from the Miss USA pageant if you
didn't if you didn't see it I it was one
of my favorite moments on television
this week I had to bring it
here she is answering a question from
nene leakes which already is insulting
that nene leakes gets to ask you a
question you have to respond but here
she is asking about women in the
workplace and then miss Utah's response
okay a recent report shows that in 40%
of American families with children women
are the primary earners yet they
continue to earn less been named what
does this say about society I think we
can relate this back to education and
how we are continuing to try to strive
to
[Music]
figure out how to create jobs right now
that is the biggest problem and I think
especially the men are seen as the
leaders of this and so we need to try to
figure out how to create education
better so that we can solve this problem
thank you thank you Utah thank you sir
yes absolutely thank you miss Utah I
look in her defense we do need to learn
how to create education better I just
didn't know men was in charge of this
thing men was in charge of this thing
and we need to create education better
so that look at my tits she should have
just said that at one point just look
how [ __ ] hot I am education Ralph's a
rare beast in them in the beauty pageant
world that's honey boo boo senior right
there man it's good to be hot because
she'll probably do well in life long as
no one ever asked her question she'll be
fine I like how the audience had her
back to me yeah yeah and they were just
like Oh stupid dumb dumb dumb dumb lose
charge chanting for it but she Bush
wouldn't stop it was like a [ __ ]
filibuster of duh by the way well my
favorite band is filibuster down there's
a lot of Jersey stuff going on the news
this week we had Tony Soprano of course
passed away we had the Lenox City where
Amanda Bynes was found it now Wildwood
New Jersey which for me in the summer
time me and Wildwood that is that is
there two of the scenes are down the
shore that's where I used to hang all
the time why would New Jersey was where
I used to go with that person apparently
with that guy we'd be down the shore in
Wildwood that's where I would go and
this week why would New Jersey passed a
ban on guys letting their pants sag and
showing their underwear
you can't let your your jeans sag down
around your hips and you can't show your
underwear it's a ban on that you can't
do that well you can do it but then you
have to pay the price and the price may
be up to $200 and 40 hours of community
service if you wear sagging pants you
know who put this law into place fat
people we hate those [ __ ] handlebars
and the ridge and [ __ ] down to the dick
we don't have that while we're talking
about pants your boyfriend Alexander
Skarsgard was in the news oh I just
watched you watch True Blood season
premiere I have not seen it yet is
hotter and ever man you love him you
well I would eat a mouthful of that
vampire oh man he's a beautiful man very
attractive you know I was thinking as a
as I watched Man of Steel is that I
looked at Henry Cavill who's just a just
a gorgeous specimen well Cosel all real
- yeah it's like we really need to make
this whole guy guy thing more acceptable
yeah I agree because because I'm not gay
but I would like to [ __ ] Henry Cavill I
really would and I know that's how you
feel about Alexander Skarsgard just to
have a more relaxed situation so that I
can [ __ ] a couple guys and not have
people talk about it so much you know
why don't you be the John Glenn of this
[ __ ] man go first or the Neil Armstrong
either one or the Buzz Aldrin more
important [ __ ] yeah the buzz alexander
skarsgård says he doesn't mind being
nude in front of people on that Tru
Blood show he's naked a lot of here's
the reason why
Us Weekly magazine he tells I was 14 the
first time I saw my dad wearing pants he
was always naked he writes about his
upbringing and his dad is the dude and
Thor yeah he's Galan skarsgård yeah he's
also a Good Will Hunting yeah he he was
naked around the house all the time my
parents did the same thing I read this
but might but having seen my parents
naked it made me want to put clothes on
people you were a rebel yeah I became a
layers man because I was like nobody
needs to see that man
and porch over your dick and [ __ ] like
that but now when I look in the mirror I
do see my naked father that sounds
dirtier than I meant it but each and
every week we likely take a look at
movies that we know will suck singing
along with our thank you guys like a
Rocky Horror Picture Show version of the
show right there
they've been having a good time this was
a movie that we said would suck and now
I think might suck less depending on
what happens after the suckage if that
makes any sense
the Highlander was gonna be remade
they're gonna relate the high/low there
they can't remake it there can be only
one that's right Sean Connery Chris
Rowland bear of course in the original I
love Sean Connery as a Spaniard because
he's got cuz you know cuz he's got that
Spaniard vibe about him yes of course
I'm from Spain yes pie-yah
yes
Oh get me some things that are Spanish
there for a minute did I buy him as a
Spaniard you couldn't pull anything I
kept going to Mexico I kept pulling my
mind I kept my mind good go to Mexico
anestine utz Ryan Reynolds was supposed
to star in the reboot of Highlander yes
he has dropped out of that reboot so we
may have all dodged the bullet we may we
may have spare doesn't mean it's still
not gonna happen no you're right because
it could be you know carrot top or
somebody does this we don't know but I
know this one will suck they have just
announced the remake of poltergeist it's
going to be happy oh no really
yeah
MGM and 20th Century Fox announced this
week that they are co-financing and
distributing a remake of poltergeist
it is leave it alone I think that was
the message of bolter case right there
[Applause]
is peace and serenity in the light hair
Lam this house is clean how do you how
do you remake that movie and I've always
heard people say well you know the
20-somethings they don't watch old
movies this movie you know doesn't mean
thing to them they need a new holy [ __ ]
those people there's we have never lived
in a world more where all media is
accessible to you in so many [ __ ]
ways do a little work and download
poltergeist or rent poltergeist or bi
poltergeist and just watch it it's fine
the way it is I guarantee you the new
poltergeist won't be as good as the old
poltergeist this tobe Hooper wasn't tobe
Hooper yeah it is a really fantastic
he's tobe Hooper under the stewardship
of Steven Spielberg right so you got a
guy who did the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and a guy who did every other movie that
wasn't the Texas Chainsaw that's great
and it's it still holds up man to this
day that kids creepy the whole thing's
[ __ ] creepy I even like poltergeist
to like the old man the old man is a
[ __ ] terror that guy I was I borrowed
from that for the imagery for red state
from that guy I love to him and he was
like God is in his holy tail he shows up
in the back yo the back door why would
they do
I can't believe Steven Spielberg's gonna
let that happen I don't know if he has
to say so I wonder if MGM owns it
because it looks like they're involved
and Fox is co-financing and producing he
says Sam Raimi is going to be the
producer of the thing Oh
bad form
yeah well I guess if somebody's gonna
remake it it might as well be sam raimi
it's not gonna be but I mean that's the
thing think about it it's gonna happen
regardless at least Sam Raimi's like
[ __ ] it I'll make sure they don't [ __ ]
it up too bad so many iconic moments
come from that film that even people
don't know the film know the moment
they're here for God's sakes that still
it's a thing that's still a thing
you can't she's like rush over children
oh I didn't say you had to [ __ ] the
little lady I'm saying that moment was
pretty cool yeah I still I don't throw
tennis ball into a closet anymore
because I'm afraid it's gonna come back
all covered with slime I don't know
what's gonna happen
Smith and I of course are
dyed-in-the-wool geeks and so each and
every week we have to do a little
service to the geek news
[Music]
I am not a gamer I am NOT proud of that
fact I do not say that with any sort of
superiority I just found myself too
[ __ ] busy to play video games I got
enough on my plate with the computer
time that I waste and with the
television time that I waste and I have
a child and a wife and they demand a
small portion of my time why are you
getting hostile at the end of the show
it's like you turn on the audio I'm just
saying every time I say I'm not a gamer
there's a certain percentage of people's
like what the [ __ ] wrong with you you
don't play video games like as if it's
some sort of weakness so I have to
apologize for myself sometimes I don't
play videos disclaimers if however I may
have to change that all now because this
week there was a release about the new
video game Batman Arkham origins and
PlayStation 3 owners apparently will get
to exclusive a downloadable character
downloads that they can put on Batman as
the costume you can wait you can wear
different costumes and that there will
be specifically for ps3 owners they will
get these costumes one of which is
Azrael if you remember from the comic
books remember ones Bane when Bane broke
Batman's back he was the one that John
Paul Valley was the one who took over
for Batman and they've got that skin you
can put on the character or the best
skin ever on a video game character ever
can we take a look at the picture of the
other Batman that they offer
it is the buffest adam west you've ever
seen that adam west right there they
used to have to look him look skinnier
on television that's what they did you
know the actual the batman from 1966
Adam West's Batman will be a choice that
you can play this video game with it
will look absolutely wild especially in
that environment cuz he's still got all
the purple in that outfit I know it's
gonna be fun but you've never seemed
like there won't be Biff pow when you
hit people you're just gonna hit people
and [ __ ] like the real Adam West does
but then they covered it with Biff pow
no I'm talking Adam in real life he
beats people up everywhere he goes by
the way if you're Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian how do you not name your
[ __ ] daughter Adam if her last name
is West how do you miss out on that
opportunity thank God that might have
pushed that might have been your
scanners moments stole your heroes name
for your good I [ __ ] at a lot of
Avengers to talk this week as well Josh
Wheaton has confirmed that Quicksilver
or the Scarlet Witch will be characters
and I'm so [ __ ] and I was obliged in
this today to I have this movie [ __ ]
holds the Avengers is a great film it
really is yeah Aaron taylor-johnson who
plays kick ass in the kick ass movies
apparently in early talks to play
Quicksilver and The Avengers 2 movie
okay so wait and see no word on who the
Scarlet wait a second Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch like or isn't their father
magneto yeah how they gonna explain this
they're not you think they're gonna have
winking references to like you don't
want to meet our father he's attractive
I don't know how they're gonna work that
out yeah maybe you could still get it up
you know even though it's an implant or
something that he can still have kids at
an old age yeah but it's just how are
they gonna reference they don't own
those characters anymore like Fox owns
the x-men oh that's what I'm talking
about like they can't reference Magneto
unless they get permission from Fox
because Fox has cinematic rights were in
that aspect of the Marvel Universe so
how do you talk about their father
that's why I think the winking thing I
don't know just gives Scarlet Witch big
tits and no one will notice you I hope
they give it a [ __ ] outfit to man
with the pointy headpiece someone I hope
they go for that the best news for
Avengers fans is that Robert Downey jr.
signed this week to come back as Iron
Man not only for Avengers 2 but Avengers
3 as well however he said the new
agreement does not include a fourth
standalone Iron Man film so we may never
see one of those again starring Robert
Downey jr. I said he's not going to do a
fourth one because a one and a half year
old kid didn't know who he was he blames
the kid I want him to bring back which
McCord
Sam Rockwell he was in too as Justin
Hammer yeah he was great and he was like
at the end he was just like yo you'll be
here for me but he was so damn good in
that movie we came back in spider-man 2
News they've already scheduled a third
and fourth film in the franchise I was
first 2016 2018 we're gonna get the
third and fourth films there's currently
filming spider-man 2 as we speak and
they just cut the Mary Jane character
from that film
what shailene woodley the actress from
Secret Life of the American teenager and
The Descendants was gonna be she was
gonna be Mary Jane Watson
they have cut her role from the film she
shot the role and then they cut it from
the film I'm gonna assume that it has
everything to do the story and not the
perform that's what Marc Webb the
director said he said we're trying to
focus on Peter and
Wynn's relationship and so we did really
didn't have room for another character
she'll come into the third and fourth
films however they're saying that they
may recast by the time they get to those
films so this actress is it's a bummer
man
Gene Roddenberry who created Star Trek
he's gone into space his his ashes he's
dead but I didn't kill him gene his wife
may Joe Barrett who played Christine
chapel nurse Chapel on that show and
Scotty doin their their ashes are gonna
be shot into space they've all been in
space before again as ashes but they
came back into the atmosphere they
burned back in upon reentry this time
they're putting them a special spaceship
with a solar sail that will take them
out beyond Earth's atmosphere where no
man has ever gone before
yes and then that the craft will circle
the Sun and will never come back again
to earth to their final resting place
we'll be in space and they're gonna
slingshot around the Sun like they did
in four go back in time and come back
with whales captain there to be whales
head I thought they were on [ __ ] the
Star Trek crew was trapped on the
[ __ ] that it's a small world man this
is a heartwarming story this hospital in
South Paulo Brazil teamed up with Warner
Brothers to create a encouraging
soothing atmosphere for kids who are
going through cancer and turned their
children's ward into the Hall of Justice
for the Justice League Oh hear about
this this makes me want to get sick that
is adorable and all the chemotherapy for
these kids with cancer yeah
they have couched it in superhero
wrappings so they tell the kids
this isn't medicine this is just you
getting your superpowers replenished and
they give them the chemotherapy couched
in their favorite superhero basically
here's a picture of how it comes now
when the kids see it they get to pick
which one they want
and they give them their superhero
medicine such a small thing but makes
I'll say it makes all the difference the
attitude the kids have been going into
chemotherapy which I can imagine if your
child is just terrified versus something
like you're gonna get you know shot with
superhero juice which is something Adam
West used to do to me when I was a small
boy I took it gladly but that's what the
cool thing yeah Brazil was the first
company to do it team up with Warner
Brothers I think all Children's Hospital
should do this especially if you're
gonna sit there these it's a long time
and make it a little fun for them except
just get ready to answer questions when
they're like what the [ __ ] happened what
happened to the kid says I don't like
superheroes
I'm just saying you can't have something
for every kind of like you know [ __ ]
strawberry shortcake chemo and again I
never like every character chemo
I just couldn't conceive of a world
where some kid was like I know you
couldn't remember the Minnesota
Minnesota guy who found the Action
Comics number one in the walls of the
house he was this [ __ ] he was tearing
up the 75 year old house he's tearing
out the insulation and he found inside
the installation of the walls a Action
Comics number one first appearance of
Superman and he sold it at auction for
$175,000 it was just in the wall okay so
he goes back to work that week this
[ __ ] guy and he's he's tearing down
the walls and he finds Superman number
four in the walls same house same guy
finds another rare Superman comic in the
walls man that's if you could keep going
to get build the whole collection who
owned this house and who are they
stuffing their walls with the comic
books what kind of sick [ __ ] own this
house beforehand maybe they were scared
man somebody was coming for him like put
up in the walls yeah here's a cover
here's the cover of Superman for it so
it looks like this is his it is the
second appearance of Lex Luthor in this
comic book the first ever mention of The
Daily Planet so it's a highly prized
collectible Wilcock edition was a shitty
but even in shitty condition they said
it could pull up to $5,000 so just start
tearing you should apart people that's
the moral the story go home get an axe
and just tear down your [ __ ] walls
every one of them they own up my
childhood walls would be all hustler
penthouse crusty sweat socks generations
of dead children and lastly the lone
Ranger's in the news this week
armie hammer who plays the masked man in
the upcoming feature film didn't
interview with Elle magazine talking
about his relationships they want to
know you know that is the one Ranger
[ __ ] basically it's what they were asked
and he said he's married now but he had
a lot of crazy relationships he was
young because look at the guy army
hammer
there's another guy by the way once it
becomes cool to like blow guys put me in
line you know I'm saying I'd Armie
Hammer he's a good-looking dude he said
he who dated one girl let me quote from
him once chick I try one chick tried to
stab me when we were having sex he said
I thought that was his job she said to
me true love leaves scars and you don't
have any and then she pulled out a
butcher knife and tried to stab me with
oh my god of course I promptly broke up
with her seven months later a girl is
that crazy was gonna murder you during
sex is just the best [ __ ] you've ever
had I guarantee really yeah yeah I was
threatened to a good knife boy once my
girl no I didn't like in the middle of
sex
army happens all the breaks for you is
after the surge I didn't come how dare
you sir your big balls were in the way
speaking of big things each and every
week we like to close out the show with
a look but just how big is the member of
Liam Neeson your kind folks keep going
each and every week to nice and calm to
enter your own facts about the size of
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] this is this week's
compilation of the best of those facts
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big amanda
Bynes called it beautiful on Twitter
it's unheard of Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it was once chased into the hills by
a mob of angry villagers bearing flaming
torches and pitchforks Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it can leave Scientology
any time at once that is [ __ ] big
that's powerful Vega that nobody gets
that yeah Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that days before he ejaculates thousands
of animals flee the surrounding area
they have a sense about these fairs Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Liam got an
erection and killed off most of the
characters in Game of Thrones I had no
idea that was the cause Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big
before Liam visited Arizona it was known
as the grande Hyman Grand Canyon Lees
I'm laughing about the ones coming up
I'm sorry this one made me laugh so hard
now I've set it up too much now you're
gonna be disappointed [ __ ] it Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he [ __ ]
mary-kate Olsen Ashley's ribs hurt that
may be the smartest [ __ ] version of
the Liam Neeson stock job ever just
wanna say good night on that one
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big you can fit
all the names of Taylor Swift's
ex-boyfriends on it Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big when he was circumcised onions
cried
[Applause]
this one for Grandma man good batch this
week
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Superman had no choice but to kill it to
save all mankind ladies and gentlemen of
Hollywood have you had a good time this
evening as always thank you so much for
coming out tonight we truly appreciate
it give it up for the amazing host of
Hollywood babble-on mr. Ralph Garman
and my good friend and co-host mr. Kevin
Smith is Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
[Music]